hogwarts legacy micro transaction
details have been revealed and elden
ring is getting better on steam deck
this week's state of play presentation
showed off brand new gameplay for
hogwarts legacy giving fans a glimpse
into the world of the famous harry
potter location and the school
activities that they'll be able to
engage in one thing you won't see on the
wizarding curriculum though are micro
transactions as avalanche community
manager chandler wood set the record
straight over on twitter players have
speculated that hogwarts legacy would
include microtransactions when the
in-game currency of moonstones used to
customize gear were revealed a few years
ago the mobile game harry potter
hogwarts mystery became notorious for
its heavy-handed use of
microtransactions when it launched in
2018 prompting a severe backlash from
fans who tried it out at the time a good
example of this is when your avatar is
essentially being strangled by vines but
the only way to escape is to wait hours
for your energy to recharge or buy gems
with real cash in order to pay for more
energy so just imagine you're like a
little like eight-year-old kid and
you're playing on your mom's phone and
you're just like yay harry potter game
and then your character gets strangled
and it's either steel mom's card
or
let my character suffer
that's to be traumatizing for a kid
another little nugget of info that was
released sometime after the stream is
that the game would be coming to
nintendo switch despite no formal
announcement from warner brothers or
nintendo the faq for hogwarts legacy
revealed that the game will be available
on nintendo's console the game was
initially announced for only playstation
and xbox as well as pc whether or not
this will be a cloud version of hogwarts
legacy or local download remains to be
seen hogwarts legacy is being produced
by disney infinity developer avalanche
software and portkey games and so far it
appears to be a faithful exploration of
what it's like to learn the magical arts
inside of that school set in the 1800s
you'll build your character up with an
upgrade tree grow your skills by brewing
potions and form friendships with your
fellow classmates though the game is set
in the popular wizarding world universe
it has been overshadowed at times by
remarks from harry potter creator jk
rowling the author has been criticized
for her transphobic comments over the
past several years and if you'd like to
know more please read jessie earle's
feature on why rowling's statements have
been so hurtful to the trans community
the link to the article will be down
below
but okay let's switch gears to alden
ring now because there's just no
escaping the game even if i wanted to
you can't hide from it now that valve
has finally fixed some of the major
issues that were plaguing elder ring
players on steam deck the company has
explained how it went about improving
stability in a discussion with digital
foundry a coder for valve has explained
how the company worked around the
problems that were previously reported
by players including the stuttering
frame rate issue that was brought up
last month as a top priority although
the stuttering issues seem to be
resolved on steam deck the issue is
still present on standard pc versions of
the game valve explained that most of
the elden ring issues were caused by
other factors saying that the shader
pipeline driven stutter wasn't the
majority of the problems the team has
seen in the game
[Music]
mario kart's new but old tracks are out
today this is wave one of eight and it
includes tracks like coconut mall paris
promenade and sky garden just to name a
few it's also important to note that if
you're a nintendo switch online plus
expansion pack member you get these at
no additional cost so make sure you
download those and show your siblings
who's boss have a good weekend i'll see
you next week
[Music]